[Musik]
Umfragen zum Jahreswechsel verraten dass
die Deutschen persönlich optimistisch
gesellschaftlich hingegen eh
pessimistisch in die Zukunft schauen
selten war der Blick der Bevölkerung auf
die Weltlage und die Situation
Deutschlands so getrübt wie heute ist
dieser Pessimismus ein Realismus oder
kann man auch viel optimistischer in die
Zukunft schauen darüber rede ich mit der
Politikwissenschaftlerin Florence gaup
Direktorin der Forschungsabteilung am
NATO Defense College in
[Musik]
romcht Frau Gau was werden uns die
nächsten Jahre bringen mehr
weltpolitische Eskalation oder doch
irgendwann eine allmähliche Rückkehr zur
Entspannungspolitik das lustige an Ihrer
Frage ist ja dass es da so viele
Antworten drauf gibt dass ich das jetzt
nicht in einem Satz zusammenfassen kann
ich sage alles ist möglich und nichts
ist fix ja sie haben ein Buch
geschrieben indem sie ein pledoer für
den positiven Blick in die Zukunft
halten richtig also sie waren natürlich
auch all den Illusionen und all den
Fallstricken und alles dem was man sich
so vormachen kann aber ihr Buch hat
einen positiven Grundtenor deswegen
hätte ich vielleicht erwartet dass sie
äh die Position vertreten zu sagen wir
leben zwar in schwierigen Zeiten aber
vielleicht wird doch alles in Zukunft
wieder ein bisschen besser als es gerade
ist aber das sage ich ja auch weil ich
sage es ist alles möglich und ich glaube
der Tenor aktuell ist ja so alles wird
ganz schlimm Klima und Krieg und sonst
was und wenn ich sag alles ist möglich
dann gibt's ja auch verschiedene
positive Zukünfte also mein Rat wäre auf
jeden Fall immer zu schauen was kann
alles noch gutes passieren und wie
kommen wir dahin mhm wovon ist das
eigentlich abhängig ob eine Gesellschaft
einen eher positiven oder einen eher
negativen Blick in die Zukunft wirft
also ist nicht ganz entschlüsselt aber
wir wissen dass hier mehr Menschen also
Individuen denken dass sie Einfluss
haben auf ihr Schicksal desto positiver
denken Sie also klassisches Beispiel ist
natürlich die USA mit diesem typischen
ne wo wir als Europäer dann gerne drüber
lächeln aber tatsächlich in Umfragen
sieht man der Durchschnittsamerikaner
denkt mein Schicksal ist im weitestgend
in meiner Hand ich glaube das ist eine
Sache das andere ist tatsächlich so ja
so eine can attitude ne das sieht man
z.B auch in Israel Israel ist ein der
Staaten mit der höchsten so Startup
Quote und viele davon fallen auch auf
die Nase ne aber es geht nicht darum
dass man ständig Erfolg hat sondern dass
man ständig versucht also ich sagen so
eine Mischung aus was die einzelnen
denken was die Gesellschaft denkt und
ich würde jetzt mal aus der das ist
jetzt aus der Hüfte geschossen ich würde
auch sagen vielleicht ein Umgang mit
Geschichte
der der nicht nicht optimistisch ist
aber der sich Geschichte anschaut nicht
als einfach nur was statis ist und was
was Schlechtes sondern woraus man auch
dusus lernen kann was gutes Lernen kann
für die Zukunft find ich z in
Deutschland sind wir eher so in
der wir sehen Geschichte als den Ort wo
ganz viel schlechte Sachen passiert sind
aberbei sind da auch ganz viel tolle
Sachen passiertm also ich finde ja ihr
ihre Diagnose nachvollziehbar dass man
sagt in Ländern wo die Menschen das
Gefühl haben sie können möglichst viel
Zukunft selber gestalten ist der Blick
in die Zukunft optimistischer das würde
ja nah liegen dass man sagt in die Bar
Demokratien denken die Leute
positiver an die Zukunft als in anderen
Gesellschaften aber ich glaube ein
kleiner Blick ins Leben ja zeigt dass
das komplizierter ist dass also gerade
in Deutschland es gibt ja neue Umfragen
dazu zwar nicht wenige Menschen für sich
selber recht positiv in die Zukunft
gucken aber dass sie in Hinblick auf die
gesellschaftliche Entwicklung und
Entwicklung der Weltpolitik sehr negativ
drauf gucken das heißt also eine
liberale Demokratie schützt nicht vor
Pessimismus absolut und auf der ander
Seite kann ich aus meinen Erfahrungen
ich war recht viele in Afrika sagen es
ist doch irre zu sehen ja wie viele auf
den ersten Blick zumindestens glückliche
Menschen die in relativer Armut leben
einem da begegnen wo man das Gefühl
haben die blicken sehr positiv auf Ihr
Leben oder in die Zukunft das heißt es
gibt offensichtlich keine direkte
Korrelation ja zwischen freiheitlichen
Wohlstandsgesellschaften und Glück auf
der anderen Seite absolut ja das ist das
ein bisschen das das Paradox weil also
objektiv gesehen wie sie gerade gesagt
haben hab wir natürlich so viel
Spielraum so viel Einfluss auf unsere
Zukünfte also auch die eigene und dann
natürlich die der Gesellschaft weil wir
weil wir wählen können weil wir so viel
Geld haben dass wir mit unserem
Konsumverhalten Sachen beeinflussen
können weil wir unsere Meinung äußern K
also wir haben eigentlich sehr viel
Freiraum aber tatsächlich ist es so dass
also es gibt eine Umfrage von uniceef
die zeigt dass eigentlich ist dieser
zukunftspessimismus so ein ich
überspitzt es mal so ein altes weißes
Problem also der Westen schaut
pessimistisch in die Zukunft und fast
überall auf der Welt schauen gerade
junge Menschen sehr positiv in die
Zukunft und Stimmen der Aussage zu meine
Zukunft wird besser als die meiner
Kinder und meine ist dieber besser
meiner Eltern und so weiter also dann
ist es für mich interessant zu fragen
warum was ist bei uns eigentlich gerade
was läuft da gerade schief und meine
Hypothese ist dass wir einfach denken
wir schauen in die Zukunft und sehen
sehen China sehen K wissen nicht genau
was ist denn jetzt unsere Rolle als
Europäer in der Zukunft früher waren wir
immer so die die alles dominiert haben
alles bestimmt haben sage ich jetzt mal
und wir tun uns schwer da jetzt was
neues reinzufüllen was irgendwie gut ist
ich würde sagen das ist meine Hypothese
dazu ja ich würde dem sofort zustimmen
also ich glaube das trifft die
gesellschaftliche Befindlichkeit dass
man das Gefühl hat wir waren zwar ganz
lange die Sieger aber wir werden es in
der Zukunft nicht mehr sein und dann
fürchten wir uns vor dieser Zukunft wir
erleben den den Aufstieg gerade der
asiatischen Staaten und den dazu
gesehenen relativen Abstieg des alten
Westens ne das sehen wir vor unseren
Augen und fragen uns wo soll dieses
kleine Europa in einer zukünftigen
multipolaren Weltordnung noch seinen
Platz und seine Rolle haben das andere
ist sie haben das ja auch angesprochen
alte weiße Männer wir leben in einer
sehr alten Gesellschaft und es gibt
sicherlich einen Zusammenhang der auch
eine Rolle spielt die Jünger
Gesellschaften sind umso optimistischer
sind sie im Regelfall ja aber was ja
eigentlich absurd ist weil also jetzt
auf eine individuelle Lebensphase
betrachtet also ich weiß nicht wie es
Ihnen geht aber ich bin heute
optimistischer als mit 20 z.B also je
älter man wird d du lassener wird man da
gibt's ja auch Studien dazu die zeigen
dass eigentlich im Gegensatz zum unserer
jugendbesessenheit ist der Mensch
glücklicher wenn er Elter ist ja im
Hinblick auf sein eigenes Leben aber
nicht im Hinblick auf die
Zukunftsaussichten für alle ja also ich
glaube wenn man älter wird dann
hoffentlich ja wird man gelassener nicht
jeder manche manche werden auch
verzweifelt oder deprimierend aber viele
Menschen werden dadurch dass sie älter
werden für sich und ihr Leben gelassener
sie blicken zurück auf alles was Sie
schon geschafft haben und die Strecke
die sie noch zu zu bewältigen haben die
erscheint ihn nicht mehr so anstrengend
vielleicht aber was die Gesellschaft
anbelangt neigen Menschen wenn sie älter
werden auch zum Kulturpessimismus also
zu denken früher wäre doch sehr vieles
besser gewesen in der Gegenwart ist es
schon schlechter und in der Zukunft wird
es noch schlechter genau genau was
natürlich auch eine Verzerrung ist das
wissen wir auch dass es nicht dass es
kein Fakt ist aber was mich interessiert
ist erstens woher kommt diese Sprache
weil die Sprache die wir verwenden ist
negativ sie haben gerade gesagt ähm also
die Gesellschaft altert die Gesellschaft
schrumpft wir werden nicht nur älter
sondern auch weniger wo ist wir sind
nicht mehr die Sieger also warum wird
das alles so negativ auch in Sprache
ausgedrückt also wir schrumpfen ja nicht
sondern wir kehren zurück zu einer Größe
die wir vorher schon hatten und auch
überhaupt diese Vorstellung dass macht
ne also eigentlich geht's ja jetzt um
macht wenn wir reden über Geopolitik
reden dann fragen wir wo ist unser Platz
und dann schaut man so klassisch auf wie
groß ist mein Land wie groß ist meine
Armee wie groß ist meine Bevölkerung
alles ist immer so groß und quantitativ
aber eigentlich kann man sich auch
vorstellen dass es qualitativ ist wir
müssen im 21 Jahrhundert nicht mehr die
größte Armee haben sondern die die am
agilsten ist und vielleicht am besten
ausgerüstet technologisch und vielleicht
müssen wir nicht das größte Volk der
Welt sein sondern einfach nur das
schlauste oder das glücklichste also ich
weiß es nicht aber ich hab das Gefühl
könte Dänemark nehmen dänemark hat
glaube ich 4 Millionen Einwohner und bei
allen Glücks Befragungen ja stehen die
Dänen immer auf einem der ersten drei
Plätze fin ja und Finnland auch da aber
scheint da nicht mal die Sonne jetzt
könnte man aber sagen das sind Länder
die haben einen anderen Vorteil wenn man
sich anguckt die großen ökonomischen
Veränderungen ein Land wie Dänemark das
nie eine nennenswerte Industrie hatte
und nur 4 Millionen Einwohner kann von
der Politik gestaltet werden und zwar
stark gestaltet werden man kann also
enorm Industriepolitik und so weiter
machen über Dienstleistungsgesellschaft
an die Herausforderung der
Digitalisierung anpassen mit nur 4
Millionen Leuten und nichts zu verlieren
jetzt guckt man sich Deutschland an ja
dass die Grundlage des deutschen
Wohlstands ja liegt in der Fertigung ja
in der industriellen Fertigung wir sind
groß geworden nicht als dienstleistungsn
sondern als Industrienation wir kriegen
sehr große Probleme im 21 Jahrhundert
was unsere klassische Rolle als
Industrienation anbelangt ja Kohle ist
sowieso schon weg Stahl hat am Bedeutung
verloren Automobilindustrie blickt in
berechtigt in keine gute Zukunft und
wenn wir dann überlegen wie wir diesen
großen schweren auf bisschen auf Grund
gelaufenen rostigen Tanker wenden wollen
dann sehen wir eine politische Situation
in der egal welche Partei in Deutschland
regiert man das Gefühl hat das ist alles
vermentest
überall ja an jeder Ecke lauert entweder
die Bürokratie ja oder die Medien regen
sich über irgendwas auf und so weiter
und man hat das Gefühl sie hat sagt ja
vorher es gibt einen Zusammenhang ja
zwischen Optimismus und
Gestaltungsmöglichkeit und die Leute
verlieren den Glauben daran dass sich
Politik in Deutschland überhaupt noch
gestalten lässt also das ist ein
interessanter Zusammenhang ich glaube
tatsächlich dass wahrscheinlich die die
Innovationsfähigkeit im direkten
Zusammenhang mit diesem Optimismus oder
Zukunfts Optimismus irgendwie steht aber
tatsächlich würde ich noch dazu sagen
dass ich glaube es herrscht so die
Illusion es muss alles super sein jetzt
damit auch die Zukunft super sein kann
und eigentlich ist es genau andersrum
wenn die Gegenwart wirklich weh tut dann
kommt erst der Druck
zu tragen der dann wirklich irgendwie
Visionen kreiert oder wirklich diesen
den Impuls nach Lösung zu suchen
deswegen ich würde sagen wir sind
wahrscheinlich gerade schon in dieser
diesem schmerzvollen Geburtsprozess we
wenn Sie sich anschauen ähm die 50er
Jahre z.B ja da war ja auch so ein so
ein so ein zukunftshöhenflug auch in
Deutschland aber gleichzeitig hatte man
total Angst vor Atomkrieg und wusste
auch nicht wie es weitergeht irgendwie
überhaupt in der geteilten Deutschland
Frage wirtschaftlich die
kriegsrückkehrer und so weiter also die
50er Jahre werden heute dargestellt wie
so eine ha popaya Zeit aber es war auch
eine Zeit großer Angst deswegen würde
ich die These Wagen gerade wenn es
wirklich schlimm ist in der Gegenwart
ist der Moment eben solche Fehler zu
erkennen zu verändern und sagen okay und
jetzt muss es aber auch nach vorne geht
das fehlt mir so ein bisschen
Deutschland schauen wir gerade nur auf
auf die Seite was läuft den alles schief
im Jetzt und wird deswegen noch schiefer
laufen in der Zukunft anstatt zu sagen
okay was kann man denn hier eigentlich
machen wie kann man es besser machen wie
kann man ich habe das Gefühl es ist so
defitistisch das ist alles schon die
Schlacht ist schon geschlagen alles
schon vorbei jetzt ist ja ein bisschen
die Frage wie viel von alled dem worüber
wir reden ist deutsche Mentalität
Wechsel der Mentalität von den 50ern bis
heute und wie viel ist
Realismus weil man kann ja sagen ich
hatte vorhin dieses Bild von dem Tanker
gebraucht ja innenpolitisch Bildung
Bildungsreform große kriegen wir nicht
mehr
hin große Reformen oder Revolution un
Gesundheitssystem kriegen wir nicht mehr
wird immer teurer unbezahlbarer niemand
weiß wie das in Zukunft weitergehen
Rentensystem im Grunden völlig kaputt
wird mit 100 Milliarden im Jahr
bezuschustst müsste dringend durch etwas
anderes ersetz den kriegen wir nicht
mehr hin stattdessen haben wir immer
Schönheitschirurgie an krebskranken
Patienten und man hat sich gewöhnt egal
wer in der Regierung ist kriegen wir
alles nicht mehr hin weltpolitisch ja
wir haben gedacht der Kalte Krieg ist
vorbei jetzt kommt der halte Krieg
wieder zurück ja wir haben wir stehen
wieder vor außenpolitischen
Bedrohungssituationen etwas wo wir
gedacht haben da haben wir nie wieder
was mit zu tun Aufrüstung ist plötzlich
ein riesiges Thema nachdem eigentlich
jahrzehntelang immer nur noch von
Abrüstung die Rede war es gibt wieder
Feinde es gibt wieder Bedrohungen es
gibt Einstellung da drauf es gibt das
ökologische disaster als das große dokl
Schwert das überhaupt über der ganzen
Menschheit liegt das ist ja jetzt
sozusagen nicht ein Mangel an Realismus
wenn man dann sagt mir fällt es schwer
positiv in die Zukunft denken also wenn
sie so formulieren ist es natürlich also
ich würde als erstes sagen ist alles
auseinanderbauen ne also nicht alles auf
einmal man kann keinen Elefanten in
einem Rut sie kennen vielleicht diesen
Ausdruck ne wie ist man einen Elefanten
ja natürlich nicht in einem in einem
Rutsch also sollte man wahrscheinlich
einfach keine Elefanten essen aber
erstmal ist alles auseinanderbauen das
zweite ist
wir sehen z. gerade bei Klimawandel da
passiert unglaublich viel
dieses Jahr hat wird Deutschland 70%
weniger CO2 ausstoßen äh seit also wir
Vergleich mit 1990 also der Trend alles
passiert eigentlich halt aber noch nicht
schnell genug ich denke schon und das
ich denke aber trotzdem dass wir dass
wir auf dem richtigen Weg sind und das
natürlich es muss noch viel mehr
passieren der Druck darf nicht
nachlassen ich würde nicht sagen wenn
sie sich das IPCC das das Abkommen den
den den den ersten Bericht der diese
Szenarien aufgemalt hat für den
Klimawandel das allererste hat
vorausgesagt das schlimmste Szenario ist
5° über der präindustriellen Zeit jetzt
sind wir on Track für 2,5 oder bis 3 das
heißt wir sind schon ganz schön weit
runtergegangen das muss man eben ab und
zu deswegen sage ich auch die
Vergangenheit hat auch gute Beispiele es
ist schon wahnsinnig viel passiert weiß
nicht ob sie das Buch factfulness
kennen genau es es ist viel Positives
passiert das muss man sich immer wieder
vor Augen füren nicht um die Gegenwart
zu negieren sondern um sich seine eigene
Wirksamkeit
wirkungsigkeitlar was kann man
eigentlich alles ne ich würde eher nicht
nur so Korrektiv sondern auch dass ein
bewusst wird was man eigentlich alles
verändern kann weenil man Geduld Spucke
Ressourcen und natürlich Vision dahinter
klemmt ne und wenn sie sie sagten ja
gerade irgendwie Schönheitschirurgie am
Krebspatienten man braucht halt eine
langzeitvision um alle diese Sachen in
Griff zu kriegen ja jetzt sie sagten
gerade Alterung ähm wir sehen gerade im
Gesundheitsbereich passiert wahnsinnig
viel ich red jetzt nicht von von der
Vorsorge in Deutschland sondern ich sag
so wie man besser altert ja so dass wenn
wir zwei Glück haben dann wird Alzheimer
wahrscheinlich schon behandelbar sein
wenn es dann soweit ist ja oder das
Krebsraten runtergeht also man muss
immer wieder schauen auf wer arbeitet
schon an einer Lösung wann werden wir
Sie erreichen wahrscheinlich halt nicht
dieses Jahr aber irgendwann halt dann
schon also Realismus ja aber es darf
nicht lähmen und das ist das Problem
wenn man zu viel Negativität hat dann
passiert eben das was man Kassandra
Komplex nennt so wie die die Trojaner
dann nicht auf Kassandra hören die sie
waren dann macht man nämlich gar nichts
mehr und das ist das was mich stört
genau also die ich bin völlig ihrer
Meinung dass Pessimismus auch keine
Lösung ist für viele reicht das
anscheinend ja und das ein ein Optimist
der sich in sein idealen getrügt hat
immer noch ein besseres Leben gelebt hat
als ein Pessimist ja der jeden Tag auf
Neue beschätigungen wartet also und dass
eine eine Gesellschaft die die
optimistische oder zuversichtliche
Dimension verliert ja dass die allen
Grund hat äh äh auch zu scheitern und
das war also quasi auf die Perspektive
die die positive Zukunftsperspektive
kann keine Gesellschaft bei Strafe ihrer
inneren Kollision überhaupt verzichten
das sowieso aber ich glaube da kommt
noch was anderes dazu woher kommt denn
eigentlich diese Anspruchshaltung dass
wir Frieden und Wohlstand und dass wir
es so gut behalten wie wir es hatten
sagen wir es mal vor 10 Jahren weil das
so großartige Dinge sind die man sehr
gerne behalten möchte genau aber es gibt
keinen Anspruch darauf man muss immer
darauf hinarbeiten muss immer wieder neu
und die Dinge müssen sich ändern unter
umgekehrten Vorzeichen damit diese Dinge
erhalten bleiben das ist klar jetzt
hatten wir vorhin davon gesprochen um
das Thema mal so ein bisschen auf die
weltpolitische Ebene zu machen die
Veränderung des globalen Gleichgewichts
kann man es ja nicht sen der globalen
Ordnung oder Unordnung also die
sozusagen die ein mähliche genau also
ich benutze gerne das Wort stabiles
Ungleichgewicht das ist ein Begriff aus
der Ökologie ne es gibt einm so die
esoterische Vorstellung die Natur
befende sich in einem ökologischen
Gleichgewicht und da müsste man die
Frage stellen wann ist denn das so
gewesen ja alles in der Natur befindet
sich in einem Ungleichgewicht aber
manche Ungleichgewichte sind über Jahr
Millionen Jahre stabil das ist und
eigentlich ist es ja in der Weltpolitik
nicht über Jahr Millionen Jahre aber im
Grunden genauso es gibt also eigentlich
immer provisorische Ordnung die für eine
bestimmte Zeit stabil sind bis sie dann
durch sozusagen andere Ordnungen oder
Unordnungen die halbwegs stabil sind
ersetzt werden und wir erleben jetzt
halt eben diese große Verschiebung also
den relativen Bedeutungsverlust des was
jar Westen nennen also USA und Europa
auf der einen Seite und dem dem
allmählichen Aufstieg zuletzt sehr
schnell vielleicht in zukun ein bisschen
langsamer aber insgesamt der asiatischen
Staaten es könnte man unter
gerechtigkeitstheoretischem
Gesichtspunkt sagen es war ja auch
komisch dass eine Minderheit der
Weltbevölkerung die weltspielregeln
festgelegt hat pas ja auch vielleicht
nicht mehr ins 21 Jahrhundert Frank
sirieren der hier zu Gast war sagt na
wenn wir 1,4 Milliarden Menschen in
China haben dann müssen die bei 8
Milliarden Weltbevölkerung auch
irgendwie vergleichbar adäquat global
repräsentiert sein also auch politischen
Einfluss gewinnen auf der anderen Seite
haben wir Angst davor ja und stellen uns
diese Zukunft nicht positiv vor sondern
sagen das eine bedrohliche Zukunft
vielleicht nicht für die Menschheit aber
zumindestens für uns was ist eher ihre
Lesart dass sie sagen es ist gut dass
ich das verändert und da muss etwas
Neues wachsen oder sagen Sie wir müssen
das alte um alles in der Welt
verteidigen das sage ich natürlich näes
das ist natürlich eine Steilvorlage aber
erstens ich wollte sie nur noch aufsag
machen sie haben gerade äh schon wieder
diese also es ist nicht sie sondern dass
sie benutzt natürlich die Wörter die in
diesem Zusammenhang im Umlauf sind
Abstieg und Aufstieg ne also als wären
wir irgend so eine Hitparade der
Weltpolitik und Bedeutungsverlust also
als hätte wer macht etwas was man hat
oder nicht hat ich sehe es anders ich
glaube also erstens äh tatsächlich dass
auch wenn aktuell jetzt wir sind ja als
Demokratien seit also seit es
Demokratien gibt jetzt die moderne
Demokratie sind wir bis zum Jahr 2000
angestiegen als ne als Regierungsmodell
wir sind jetzt ungefähr bei der Hälfte
viele von denen sind Imperfekt aber
trotzdem nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg g
waren glaube ich 16 oder 20% der Staaten
auf der Welt waren demokratische Staaten
also das Modell ist vielleicht jetzt
nicht weiter expansionsfähig aktuell
aber ich finde durchaus dass das was wir
repräsentieren so als ne was man als
Mensch sein will oder was man anstreben
will ist nach wie vor in vieler
Hinsichten attraktives
aber natürlich und das geht auf ihre
Frage jetzt zurück ne wie groß machen
wir jetzt den Tisch damit alle dran
Platz haben ich persönlich finde das ist
eigentlich das Weiterdenken der
Demokratie ne also auf globaler Ebene
kann es nicht sein dass eine eine kleine
Gruppe von Staaten entscheidet was die
Norm ist in der Welt also dieses dieses
eine Buch the rise of the rest ich finde
ja auch schon den Titel so ein bisschen
ehrlich gesagt beknackt so der Aufstieg
des Restes als wärden der Rest vom
Schützenfest so ungefähr das ist
durchaus ein gleichstellungsgedanke zu
sagen ja auch China auch Saudi-Arabien
auch auch Nigeria was weiß ich alle
Staaten haben irgendwie eine Stimme und
und können auch was beitragen oder
sollen auch was beitragen zu so einer
globalen denkordnung also eigentlich
finde ich wenn sie sich Star Trek
anschauen meine lieblingsreferenz ja so
Raumschiff Enterprise wir näherern uns
vielleicht mit vielen Ach und Krach aber
immer mehr dieser Vorstellung dass es
eine globale einen globalen Ansatz gibt
für Probleme und eben nicht so im Kalten
Krieg der eine Block und der andere
Block sondern wir können mit China
uneins sein wenn es um Taiwan geht aber
wir arbeiten zusammen wenn es um
Klimawandel geht wenn es um
Weltwirtschaft geht wenn es um digitale
Regulierungen geht und so weiter also
ich glaube also ich würde die Leute
einladen zu sagen ja je mehr Leute dabei
sind je diverser es ist desto besser für
alle aber Veränderung bringt immer
Unruhe mit sich und wir sind jetzt
gerade in dieser Veränderung und gerade
wenn wir so Wörter benutzen wie Verlust
und Abstieg und schrumpfen und altern
natürlich verkauft man es dann keinen
als wir machen den Tisch jetzt einfach
mal ein bisschen größer und es wird
lustiger mm also bei der positiven
Vision die sie jetzt gebracht haben ist
St Trek Vision ja einer einer einer
Weltregierung von gleichberechtigten ist
eine sehr sehr positive
Vorstellung Befürchtung ist so ein
bisschen wir sind recht weit davon weg
ja wir werden bewegen und bewegen uns
eigentlich im Augenblick eher in die
Gegenbewegung also ich würde sagen wir
waren da schon mal näher dran so in der
Zeit in den 90er Jahren als dieses
enorme Wachstum von Demokratien in der
Welt einsetzte von 20% Demokratien auf
fast 60% Demokratien wobei wenn wir uns
ehrlich machen sollen was in erster
Linie entstanden sind sind nicht
lupenreine Demokratien das stimmt
sondern sondern Oligarchien in den
gewählt wir aber finden sie es nicht
interessant dass auch Oligarchien jetzt
zumindest so tun als würden sie Leute
befragen das Konzept dass der Bürger
befragt wird ist ja auf jeden Fall jetzt
schon salonfähig richtig also die Anzahl
der Wahlen ja sind enorm hat sich enorm
ausgeb breitet und im nächsten Schritt
müsste dann hinter den Wahlen noch ein
bisschen mehr von dem stehen vielleicht
was wir uns unter einer guten Demokratie
funktionieren weniger Korruption
funktionieren Institutionen
Gewaltenteilung und solche Dinge ne ja
also ist eine positive Vision ich würde
sagen ist zumindestens in Stocken
geraten gegenwärtig und ich erlebe das
weil sie sind ja auch militärexpertin
ich höre sehr viel von Militärs aber
auch von von anderen Politikern das
sagen wir befinden uns nicht auf dem Weg
in eine St Weltregierung sondern wir
befinden uns in einer systemischen
Rivalität ein Wort was ich in letzten
zwei Jahren pausenlos gehört habe
systemische Rivalität in erster Linie
gegenüber China systemische Rivalität
hört sich für mich immer so an wie im
Kalten Krieg Kapitalismus versus
Kommunismus ja wir werden sehen wer der
Stärkere und der bessere ist diese Frage
ist Gott sei Dank entschieden aber jetzt
wird gemacht als wä es sozusagen die
Frage es kann nur ein System geben also
entweder gewinnen irgendwann langfristig
gesehen die liberalen Demokratien od
oder es gewinnt der chinesische
Totalitarismus ist das eine realistische
Beschreibung der Lage
also das sind ja zwei Komponenten in
Ihrer Frage ne das eine ist also
beschreiben wir den Istzustand korrekt
und wird es dann auch so weitergehen
also ich glaube tatsächlich das ist das
ist so wir sind in einer Situation in
der wir also sage ich mal die NATO oder
der Westen uns gegenüber stehen haben
Russland China gerade die beiden
gemeinsam als militärische Mächte die so
wie die Weltordnung jetzt ist das aktiv
in Frage stellen also militärisch aber
auch diplomatisch wirtschaftlich die
wollen eine andere Weltordnung wie wir
sie wollen und natürlich führt es zu
Spannungen und auch ja mit mit Russland
sowieso natürlich zu einem militärischen
Konflikt der in der Ukraine ausgetragen
wir es geht finde ich muss ganz klar
sein es geht in der Ukraine nicht nur um
die Ukraine es geht tatsächlich um eine
größere Weltordnung m aber und jetzt das
finde ich eigentlich interessanter Teil
heißt es dass dann über kurz od lang
unausweichlich zu einem Krieg kommt oder
dass es dann auch so bleibt also sie
sind ja Philosoph Hegel sagt ja auch
nicht diese Reise in eine bessere
Zukunft wird ohne ohne ABS und down sein
ne also vielleicht sind eigentlich
gerade diese Momente die schwierigen
richtiger Teil dieses Prozesses nach
vorne weil man sich austauschen muss mit
dem anderen man wenn man okay wir haben
alle eigentlich keine Lust auf Konflikt
ich rede jetzt nicht mal von Krieg aber
einfach auf Spannung aber vielleicht ist
es Teil dieses natürlichen Prozesses
nach vorne ich würde deswegen nicht
sagen über kurz oder lang wird's krachen
und es wird zu Krieg kommen zu dem
dritten Weltkrieg
und so weiter sondern und das ist ja
auch unser Job als NATO indem man
signalisiert bis hierhin und nicht
weiter indem man ein gewisses
Kräfteverhältnis hat eben baut man Krieg
überhaupt erst richtig vor das sieht
dann auf den ersten Blick ein bisschen
unlogisch aus oder absurd weil man ja
aussieht als würde man eben Krieg
absolut in der wegung ziehen aber genau
das kann eben dann dazu führen dass er
eben nicht passiert also ich wird wie
gesagt sagen es ist alles möglich es ist
durchaus möglich dass es sich alles
irgendwie äh in nicht ein friedliches
wohgefallen auflöst aber in eine
konstruktive Koexistenz so würde ich das
sagen mhm versuchen mir die konstruktive
Koexistenz unter
rivalitätsgesichtspunkten näher
vorzustellen also klar das was was
letztlich keiner will und was der der
die härteste Konfrontation ist ist Krieg
davor g es den Kalten Krieg und die
andere Option ist der kalte
Frieden ja der Unterschied der der der
der der Kalte
Krieg wie wir ihn früher kannten war
gezeichnet durch systemische Rivalität
und es gibt viele Analysten des
systemischen Friedens die sagen mit
System hat das gar nichts zu tun weil es
geht hier nicht mehr um die
Überlegenheit einer bestimmten Ideologie
ja auch die Russen sind nicht davon
überzeugt dass die Art und Weise wie
Putin Russland regiert ein Erfolgsmodell
für die Welt ist das ist nicht dass es
geht nicht darum das russische
oligarchenmodell auf die Welt zu
übertragen ja oder autokratiesystem oder
wie immer wir das jetzt zu ganz genau
nennen oder anokratiesystem oder so und
auch bei China geht es offensichtlich
nicht darum diesen äh konfuzianistisch
kommunistisch kapitalistischen wertemix
der China bestimmt jetzt zur Folie für
die ganze Welt zu machen nach dem Motto
am chinesischen Wesen soll die Welt
genesen sondern Ivan krastev der hier
zuletzt zu Gast war hat gesagt
die Chinesen missionieren nicht also wo
die Chinesen hingehen Kapseln sie sich
ab und bilden Chinatowns mhm wir
befinden uns nicht in einer systemischen
rivalitätm deswegen hätten wir die
Chance nicht wieder in einen kalten
Krieg zweier zweier systemischen Rivalen
oder mehrer zu kommen sondern in eine
Situation des kalten Friedens zu kommen
wo man sagt wir haben jetzt eine
Durststrecke und Dürre Strecke ja wir
haben eine Zeit von wenig und schlechter
Diplomatie aber wir sind auch nicht in
einer systemischen rivalitätssituation
genau und der Unterschied zum Kalten
Krieg ist während dem Kalten Krieg waren
diese Blöcke also wirklich wie Blöcke
also haben nicht miteinander gehandelt
nicht miteinander kommuniziert und so
weiter jetzt haben wir so ein bisschen
eine paradoxe Situation weil wir durch
die Globalisierung wir handeln ganz viel
mit China es geht es nicht nur um China
sondern über auf der Welt es wird
gehandelt immer mehr es wird immer mehr
gereist es wird auch viel mehr
Information fließt ne und zwar jetzt
nicht nur Medien sondern eben z.B auch
ja durch durch WhatsApp also ist
unglaublich wie wie wie vernetzt
eigentlich alles ist also wir sind
eigentlich in so einer Netzwerk Logik
also alles ist miteinander verwoben und
jetzt auf einer Ebene gibt es diese
Spannungen aber alles andere
funktioniert weiter m und ich glau das
ist das wo die Leute sich schwerun ist
ein bisschen als hätte man schwierige
Beziehung mit jemand den man aber
eigentlich sehr gern hat auf andere
Weise den man vielleicht gar nicht kann
genau also eigentlich ist es es ist eine
schwierige Ehe wahrscheinlich was also
es gab ja im Kalten Krieg sehr sehr
wenig Wirtschaftsbeziehungen zwischen
zwischen dem Ostblock und der der
kapitalistischen Welt also jedenfalls es
änderte sich in den 70er Jahren durch
die Entspannungspolitik ab da hat
Deutschland russisches Gas gekriegt ja
schon seit Anfang der 70er Jahre aber
insgesamt war war wirtschaftlich der
osblock für die meisten Länder des
Westens nicht sonderlich wichtig heute
ist China für nahe zuu alle westlichen
Länder ein enorm wichtiger
Handelspartner das hat sich ja verändert
und da ging ja auch eigentlich die
Hoffnung da drauf wenn man so
aufeinander angewiesen wird da kann man
auch keine Kriege gegeneinander führen
ja das ist diese
dieser Grundgedanke dass wenn man
wirtschaftlich handelt dass man dann
kein Interesse daran hat irgendwie
militärisch gegeneinander vorzugehen das
hat jetzt mit Rut russland hat diese
Grundannahme wiederlegt wobei in der
Politikwissenschaft ist immer so wir
haben so wenig und unser Datensatz ist
so klein dass man jetzt nicht von einer
Ausnahme schließen kann dass die ganze
Regel vielleicht nicht stimmt also ich
würde sagen grundsätzlich ist es immer
noch so dass je mehr Verbindungen man
hat desto mehr Grund hat man überhaupt
miteinander zu kommunizieren und wenn
man das tut dann baut man natürlich
solchen Situationen vor also ich würde
sagen es ist nicht so das ist nicht
geschrieben dass es dass es so wirklich
auseinanderfällt es gibt auch viele
Gründe halt einfach diese ich sage jetzt
mal latent schizophrene Beziehung
aufrechtzalten wo man einerseits
miteinander muss und auch will aber
andererseits halt auch Momente hat wo
man überhaupt nicht eins ist ich glaube
eigentlich ist das so ein ich sag fast
ein Reifeprozess in der internationalen
Politik dass man eine neue Form von
miteinander finden muss mhm sie sind ja
nicht nur Analystin als
Politikwissenschaftlerin die so von oben
drauf guckt und sieht wie sich die
Strukturmuster verändern und was
wahrscheinlich ist und weniger
wahrscheinlich son sind ja auch konkret
beratend tätig und sie arbeiten
Szenarien sie arbeiten für die NATO und
können Sie so ein bisschen einen nicht
geheheimen Einblick geben in daran in
Hinblick auf das was wir hier besprochen
haben künftige weltszenarien und so
weiter worüber die NATO da nachdenkt
oder worüber sie nachdenken also das ist
jetzt kein Geheimnis deswegen können wir
darüber sprechen letzte Woche oder ich
weiß nicht irgendwann irgendwann im
Januar kam dieses hat die Bild auch
diesen Artikel gebracht über dies
bundeswehrszenario dann hat auch
der Vorsitzende des militärischen
Komitees der NATO Admiral Bauer hat auch
von einem Szenario gesprochen so nach
dem Motto Krieg mit Russland in nächsten
20 Jahren ist eines der Szenarien über
das wir nachdenken und natürlich die
Bildzeitung hat dann daraus gestrickt
Bundeswehr oder NATO rechnet mit Krieg
mit Russland und natürlich schickt es
dann schockweh und das ganze Land aber
ist ganz wichtig zu verstehen ein
Szenario ist nicht die eine Vorhersage
also es ist was ganz anderes wenn sie
sage ich mal nachts im Bett liegen und
überlegen was ziehe ich den jetzt auf
die Party an oder um wie viel Uhr gehe
ich dahin und da haben sie verschiedene
Szenarien was ich anziehe wann ich
hingehe wann ich wieder gehe mit wem ich
gehe ne da gibt's ja man produziert dann
immer 15 verschiedene Optionen und eine
wird's dann und genau das machen wir
auch also wir denken jetzt z.B bei
Russland über verschiedene Szenarien
nach was passiert wenn
wir wenn wenn die waffenlieferen so
weitergehen was passiert wenn die
Ukraine diese Richtung sich entwickelt
oder in die andere und dann dann schiebt
man es quasi immer so weiter in
Kausalketten ne was wäre wenn und das
ist jetzt nicht so da setze ich mich
nicht hin und sag ja ich glaube das ist
jetzt einfach so wir machen das in der
Gruppe da muss man dann eben auch weiß
ich nicht geschichtliche logien bringen
man muss ganz viele Daten bringen man
muss wirklich einfach Forschung dazu
betreiben sagen okay diese Kausalkette
macht Sinn also dieses Szenario halten
wir für vielleicht wenig wahrscheinlich
aber wenn es passiert dann ist es extrem
negativ und dann versucht man eben dem
vorzubauen also das ist natürlich das
Szenario an das Denken gerade alle ein
Szenario was anfängt natürlich im
Horizont aufzutauchen ist Taiwan was
wäre wenn es über im Zusammenhang mit
Taiwan zwischen USA und China irgendwie
zum Konflikt kommt aber ich muss sagen
ich gehe gerne ich nenne es immer mit
der Taschenlampe so dahingehen wo gar
keiner hinschaut ich finde so wenn viel
Aufmerksamkeit schon auf bestimmten
Szenarien ist dann lasse ich die in Ruhe
und such mir was ganz neues wir denken
z.B drüber nach was wäre denn eine
Situation z.B Deutschland fühlt sich
angegriffen aber die NATO sagt es ist
kein Bündnisfall also da denkt wir dann
über Situation nach was wäre denn was
müsste passieren wenn es großen
zeiberangriff gibt sowas z. z.B genau
also das ist ja eine politische
Interpretationsfrage wir sagen das ist
ein Angriff z.B der natoovertrag geht ja
nicht nur um Territorien das vergessen
die Leute immer also nicht nur bünd
Gebiet sondern auch Schiffe sagen wir
mal es gibt irgendwie ein Schiff wird
versenkt ein deutsches Schiff wird
versenkt wir sagen das war Russland das
war China das war sonst irgendwer und
der Rest der NATO sagt euer
geheimdienstliches Material ist nicht
überzeugend das ist kein Bündnisfall
also solche Sachen denken wir z.B auch
nach oder ganz klassisch oder was ganz
klassisch aber oft
über nicht nicht genug beachtet finde
ich alle schauen nach Taiwan aber was
ist mit anderen Hotspots ja z.B eben was
ist wenn China irgendwie eine Rakete auf
Hawaii abschießt es ist dann ein
Bündnisfall für die NATO also solche
Sachen aber ganz wichtig ist mein Job
ist ich mache mir diese großelen
Gedanken damit sie es nicht machen
müssen ne damit das eben gar nicht
passiert am besten ist wenn ich es mir
ausgedacht habe dann wird's
wahrscheinlich nicht passieren weil ich
dann die Leute so warnen kann dass sie
die die Maßnahmen treffen können das
nicht passiert es gibt greifen wir doch
mal aus der aus der der Summe der der
denkbaren Szenarien eins raus äh was
mich viel
beschäftigt es hatte mich gerade so in
der Mitte bisherig Mitte des
ukrainekrieges viel beschäftigt was wäre
eigentlich wenn die Ukraine den Krieg
gewinnt mhm
das heißt also wenn es irgendwie große
Probleme gibt im russischen Militär und
alles nicht besonders wahrscheinlich
aber es würde gelingen sie würden die
von Russland okkupierten Gebiete
zurückerobern und sie würden vielleicht
sogar die Krim zurückerobern da habe ich
mir immer die Frage gestellt was ist
denn
dann kämen sie da zu einem positiven
Ergebnis und würden sagen dann ist Ruhe
und Frieden oder hätten Sie in dem
Szenario dann Angst dass ein Land wie
Russland das nicht mehr
verteidigungsfähig ist wenn auf der Krim
amerikanische Schlachtschiffe
stationiert sind ja und oder im
Zweifelsfall Atomraketen oder was weiß
ich was auch immer also wenn Russland
dann sozusagen jegliche
großmachtsansprüche aufgegeben hätte und
dann wahrscheinlich auch innenpolitisch
kollabieren würde wäre ein solches
Russland dann nicht tatsächlich in der
Lage z.B Atomraketen einzusetzen W man
dann gar nichts mehr zu verlieren hat
spielen sie solche Szenarien durch
absolut absolut also wenn Sie sich
anschauen was passiert in der
internationalen Politik seit der Krieg
angefangen hat ist ja man genau das will
man vermeiden also man will quasi der
Ukraine ihr Recht zurückgeben ohne
Russland das ja immer dieser Ausdruck
mit dem demütigen aber ich würde sagen
ohne Russland so zu destabilisieren dass
es dann selber zu einem Problem wird und
deswegen dieses langsame nach vorne
Tasten dann diese jede Debatte um jede
Waffenlieferung geht eben darum wie kann
man der Ukraine ist eigentlich eine
chirurgische Operation eine feine
Operation wie kann man der Ukraine zu im
Recht verhelfen ohne eben diese diesen
totalen Niedergang Russlands zu
erreichen und das ist die Kunst ne also
deswegen dauert so lang ist der Zustand
mal erreicht wann ist der Zustand
erreicht wo man sagt das ist ja
zumindestens aus unserer Sicht der
ideale was hi ja immer wir müssen die
Ukraine in eine Position der Stärke
bringen das ist also erstmal
überraschend gut gelungen dann hat sich
aber nicht mehr viel getan und die Frage
wäre wie müsste ein solcher Zustand
aussehen um zu sagen jetzt haben wir die
optimalen Voraussetzungen für
friedensverhandlung kann es den
überhaupt geben also das lustige bei
Friedensverhandlungen was heißt lustig
es klingt beknackt aber eigentlich also
Friedensverhandlungen passieren dann
wenn beide Seiten erkannt haben sie
können militärisch nicht gewinnen ne und
jetzt sitze ich nicht in Russland und
kann es nicht so richtig gut beurteilen
wie Russland sieht wobei wir arbeiten
auch an der Studie aber wir wissen
natürlich dass also ist ja kein
Geheimnis dass dieses quasi was sie
gerade beschrieben haben dieses Szenario
ist würde einen riesigen Aufwand
militärisch ressourcentechnisch
Menschenleben fordern der so auf jeden
Fall jetzt in in greifbarer Nähe nicht
liegt das heißt die Fr Frage ist das
muss man die Ukrainer Fragen unter
welchen Umständen seid ihr bereit an den
verhandlungsest zurückzusehen und zu
sagen okay jetzt können wir Konzession
machen denn ultimativ muss man an den
Verhandlungstisch kommen mit der
Bereitschaft Konzessionen zu machen und
da war nicht eben davor dass mit
Zentimetermaß irgendwie davorzugehen und
zu sagen okay hier du kriegst so viel
von der Krim und wir kriegen so viel von
Donbass und weiter sondern eigentlich
ist Krieg ja was zu tief psychologisches
und deswegen sage ich immer das Beispiel
ist Israel Ägypten die Camp David ab
David Abkommen also israel hatte den
Sinai 1967 erobert Ägypten wollte den
Sinai zurück hat ein Krieg angefangen
hat den Krieg objektiv gesehen nicht
gewonnen aber dadurch Verhandlungen
herbeigeführt und dann unter
amerikanischer Egide haben die finde ich
ein einen super Friedensvertrag
abschließen können indem sie nämlich
gefragt haben worum geht's euch wirklich
über dieses Territorium hinaus hat ja
auch noch diese Form für die Ägypter war
es eine Frage der nationalen
weil sina ist ne da ist hat Moses die
Zehn Gebote empfangen hat enorme
symbolische Bedeutung und für Israel
ging es um Sicherheit die wollten
einfach nicht dass Ägypten wieder durch
den Sinai hindurch sie angreifen kann
also was war die Lösung der Sinai kehrte
zurück nach Ägypten aber demilitarisiert
das heißt Ägypten durürfte da keine
Truppen stationieren so an so einer
Lösung muss man arbeiten wo man die
beiden Seiten fragt worum geht's euch
wirklich also emotional kognitiv
psychologisch nicht eben wir brauchen
jetzt unbedingt genau dieses Territorium
sondern braucht ihr Sicherheit braucht
geht es um Anerkennung geht es um um um
Stabilität also was ist das echte
Problem das nennt man die Harvard
Verhandlungstechnik gibt's eine Analogie
zur Ukraine dass man sagen kann wenn man
aus der Ukraine ein Sinai macht also ein
eine eine Pufferzone was ja auch früher
mal gewesen ist zwischen der russischen
Einflusssphäre und der westlichen
Einflusssphäre wäre das am Ende
sozusagen die Lösung also nicht
natoaunahme und im Gegenzug Rückgabe der
besetzten Gebiete wenn auch vielleicht
mit einem gewissen Autonomiestatus wie
Südtirol in Italien also ich glaube dass
wir nicht in der Position sind der
Ukraine also quasi über ihren Kopf hin
weg zu entscheiden ne also das ist
Selbstbestimmungsrecht der Völker ist ja
also eins unserer Hauptelemente
wertemäßig für uns als Westen von glaube
ich können wir jetzt nicht sagen wir
haben euch jetzt schon Kandidatenstatus
gegeben in der EU und in der NATO ne
jetzt doch nicht
aber tatsächlich kann ich mir vorstellen
dass also vielleicht das bessere
Beispiel ist die Krim als jetzt die
Ukraine insgesamt ne weil weil viele
Ukrainer auch selber also historisch ist
die Krim auch recht spät zu Ukraine
dazugekommen als ich glaube eine der
verhandlungsmassen ist tatsächlich die
Krim aber dann kann man tatsächlich auf
militärischer Basis ne also alles was
nach dem Kalten Krieg total in Mode war
so vertrauensbildende Maßnahmen ne dass
man so gegenseitig militärische
Installationen besucht dass man
gemeinsam auf Patrouille geht dass man
in so eine Praxis kommt wo man sich viel
mehr austauscht da passiert ja gar
nichts in der Hinsicht das könnte z.B
ein Weg sein dass man so sukzessive
einfach mal dieses Spannungsverhältnis
runterfährt und natürlich kann man die
NATO auch da dazu holen denn für
Russland geht es ja zum Großteil auch um
die NATO ne also deswegen gab's ja auch
früher den NATO russlandrat da war die
Idee eben wenn man sich austauscht dann
kommt man überhaupt nicht erst in so
Situation also das ja eine Weile
funktioniert hat genau das hat eine
ganze Weile funktioniert aber
ich denke tatsächlich man muss da
kreativ sein es darf auch nicht alles so
im im Fokus der Öffentlichkeit sein also
Verhandlungen finden aus einem guten
Grund hinter verschlossenen Türen statt
und
ja Konzession machen aus dem Gedanken
heraus militärisch wird das hier nicht
mehr ne ich würde am Ende wir sind ja
schon bald am Ende noch einen ganz
anderen Kriegsschauplatz
ansprechen wir haben die klassischen
Kriegsschauplätze wie wir S in der
Ukraine haben zu Land in der Luft im
Wasser wir haben aber auch den
Kriegsschauplatz Internet wir
haben sehr sehr viel daraus gelernt es
gibt den berühmten Satz von Marshall
mclcluhen der Vietnamkrieg wurde für die
USA in den amerikanischen Wohnzimmern
verloren das heißt um einen Krieg zu
gewinnen muss man nicht nur auf dem
Schlachtfeld erfolgreich sein sondern
man muss die Moral aufrecht erhalten
dass man die Guten sind und dass es
richtig und wichtig ist für das was man
kämpft mhm und das ist ja eigentlich der
größte aufrüstungsbereich für alle
Länder die wir in den letzten letzten
Jahrzehnt quasi erlebt haben also das
das Fachwort dafür was sie natürlich
kennen ist cognitive Warfare also
kognitive Kriegsführung also zu
versuchen zum Teil mit Cyberattacken
aber auch mit mit Manipulation der
Öffentlichkeiten oder Unterwanderung
sozialer Netzwerke und so weiter immer
mehr dafür zu sorgen dass die die eigene
Deutung das eigene narrativ ja dass das
dominant wird und dass das narrativ des
Gegners möglichst wenig Chance hat
irgendwo Fuß zu fassen mhm ich habe ein
bisschen darüber nachgedacht und habe so
ein bisschen Angst vor dieser
Entwicklung aus dem Grund dass die Leute
die ja heute schon wahnsinnig
misstrauisch geworden sind in dem
Zeitalter universell verfügbarer
Information und Desinformation wenn sie
erst wissen wie stark also auch die
militärische Einflussnahme in sozialen
Netzwerken oder im Internet ist anfangen
das Vertrauen in alle zu verlieren das
scheint mir sozusagen die Rückseite
dieser Art von Kriegsführung zu sein
teilen Sie diese Sorge ja ich sag also
sie müssen sich vorstellen dass wir
heute pro Tag mehr Information neue
Information aufnehmen als ein Bauer im
Mittelalter sein gesamtes Leben ne und
wir haben überhaupt nicht was ich so
eine
informationsdiät nenne also haben
überhaupt nicht den Reflex zu sagen
vielleicht nicht alles was ich mir hier
reinziehe ist gut für mich oder richtig
und so weiter also ich würde eigentlich
sagen in den Schulen muss man schon
beibringen wie geht man mit Medien um
mit information
schaltet man auch mal ab wenn man merkt
das wird alles zu viel also ich glaube
wir sind da wirklich total im
Hintertreffen wir müssen uns also
unabhängig von Krieg oder nicht Krieg
müssen wir neues Verhältnis zu
Informationen entwickeln jetzt wenn es
um um um Krieg geht und um ja
Meinungsmache so in Anführungsstrichen
haben wir natürlich als Europäer als ich
sag bewusst Europäer we ich meine jetzt
internationale Organisation wie EU
gerade aber auch NATO so eine so eine
Art sich zu artikulieren zu sprechen die
halt so inauthentisch ist bürokratende
deutsch ne also so das polise Phrasen
drescherei wo dann da merkt man
irgendwie was wird ja eigentlich gerade
gesagt ich finde tatsächlich wenn sie
sich reden anschauen ähm z.B klar putin
ist ist ein sehr guter Redner arbeitet
viel mit Bildern ich glaube wir haben da
auch so was menschliches verloren durch
die durch zu technokratisch und ich
glaube am Ende des Tages geht um
Authentizität reden wir wirklich sagen
wir wirklich das was wir meinen sprechen
wir aus dem Herzen heraus aus der der
Emotion heraus und ich glaube so als
europäischer Bürokrat hat man Problem
mit Emotion deswegen ich würde sagen
pledoer zum echten Mensch zu zeigen wer
man ist mit seinen Schwächen auch
Gefühle zeigen das ist ultimativ die
echtere Kommunikation die NATO muss
emotionaler in der Kommunikation werden
mhm und die Gefahr von der ich gerade
gesprochen habe dass also wenn man weiß
dass natürlich die NATO weil die anderen
das ja alle auch machen ja versucht mE
mehr Einfluss auf Meinungsbildung im
virtuellen Raum zu nehmen mhm als
zweischneidiges Schwert also einerseits
Bekämpfen von trollfabriken und von
verschwörungserzählungen aber auf der
anderen Seite eben auch das Misstrauen
der Leute ja da steckt die NATO hinter
enthält natürlich auch so die Gefahr
eines Vertrauensverlustes das also was
mich wirklich oft zum Lachen bringt ist
wenn Sie sich anschauen sowas wie topgun
maveric solche Filme wo dann irgendwie
immer die NATO im Hintergrund ist immer
irgendwie der Todesstern der heimlich
irgendwas böses plant das ist glaube ich
erkannt deswegen sieht man auch jetzt
immer mehr so von den Kollegen aus der
presseabteil te ilung wenn sie mal auf
Instagram gesehen es ist jetzt der
Slogan we are NATO also man sieht
einfach immer mehr Menschen die in der
NATO Arbeiten Soldaten zivile ne so das
Ganze zu vermenschlichen zu zeigen wir
sind nicht einfach nur so ein großes
Hauptquartier und man kann da nicht
reinschauen also ich denke das das
Problem ist erkannt als solches dass man
halt nur weil man vieles macht was
geheim ist heißt es aber nicht dass dass
alles top secret ist und dass wir keine
Menschen sind nem was sind die Gründe
warum wir berechtigte glauben können
dass die weltpolitische Zukunft eine
gute sein wird ich
glaube tatsächlich man muss ein
Urvertrauen haben das ultimativ ist die
Entwicklung nach vorn schon eine
positive und deswegen würde ich sagen
ein bisschen dem Menschen an sich
Vertrauen als lernfähiges Wesen
inklusive die Deutschen und die
deutschen Politiker auch darauf
vertrauen dass die anderen Menschen auf
der Welt genauso sind sehen dass wir mit
mit Technologie mit mit mit Wissenschaft
ähm mit mit mit ja allen Arten von
menschlichem Fortschritt durchaus alle
Werkzeuge haben dass es gelingen kann
dass wenn Sie und ich im Altersheim
sitzen oder sonst irgendwo dass die Welt
eine bessere ist eine stabilere eine in
der man vielleicht ja gesund und
glücklich in die Zukunft schaut ich
glaube es ist absolut absolut möglich fr
ich danke Ihnen für das Gespräch danke
[Musik]
Ihnen
connection Abed